to put a little bit
of responsibility on you like for me
i've listened to you since the red band
olive garden days
that's the very beginning and uh there
is something in the way you communicate
about the world maybe there was others
but you're the one i was aware of
is you're open-minded and uh like
loving towards the world especially as
the podcast developed like
you just demonstrated and lived
this kind of just kindness or maybe even
like lack of jealousy
in your own little profession of comedy
it was clear that you didn't
you didn't succumb to the weaker aspects
of human nature and
thereby inspire like people like me who
i was
i was naturally probably especially in
like the 20s
early 20s kind of jealous on the success
of others
and you're really the primary person
that taught me
to um truly celebrate the success of
others and
so by way of question you kind of have a
role in this
of making a better 2025 you have such a
big megaphone is there something
you think you can do on this podcast
with the words
the way you talk the the things you
discuss
that could create a better 2025 i think
if anything
i could help in leading by example
but you know that's only going to help
the people that are listening
i don't know what else i can do in terms
of like make the world a better place
other than
express my hopes and wishes for that
and just try to be as nice as i can to
people as often as i can
but i also think that i've fallen into
this weird category particularly with
the spotify deal
where um you know i'm one of them now
i'm not a regular person anymore now i'm
like some
famous rich guy so you go from being a
regular person to a famous rich guy
that's out of touch
you know and uh that that's a real
issue whenever you're talking about the
economy
about just real life problems it's it's
interesting it kind of hurts my heart to
hear people say about elon musk he's
just a billionaire yeah
it's an interesting statement but i
think if you just continue being
you and he continue being him people
people i think people are just voicing
their worry
that you become some rich guy i don't
even know if they're doing that
i think they're just finding with the
way he describes
an attack vector right yeah and i think
he's right
i think they just uh they can dismiss
you by just saying oh
you're you're just a that you know
you're a you know you're
easily uh definable
right but there i mean there's truth to
that you if you're not careful you can
become out of touch
but you that that's an interesting thing
like how
why haven't you become out of touch like
as a human
off the podcast you don't act like uh
like you you talk to somebody like me
you don't talk like a famous person
or you you don't you don't act rich
like you're better than others there's a
certain listen i've talked to quite a
few
you have to but i've talked to special
kind of group of people that like nobel
prize winners let's say
they have sometimes have an error to
them that's
of arrogance yeah and you don't what's
that about
well you gotta know what that is right
like um
that air of arrogance comes from
drinking
your own kool-aid you you start
believing that somehow another just
because you're getting praise from all
these people that you really
are something different usually it it
exemplifies
there's something there there's where
there's a lack of struggle
you know and i think uh struggle is
probably one of the most important
balancing tools that a person can have
and for me i struggle mentally
and i struggle physically i struggle
mentally in that i like we're talking
about on the podcast we did previously
you and i on my podcast said i'm not a
fan of my work
i'm not a fan of what i do i'm my
harshest critic
so anytime anybody says something bad
about me i'm like
listen i said way worse about myself i
you know i don't like anything i do i'm
ruthlessly introspective and i will
continue to be that way because that's
the only way you can be good
as a comedian there's no other way you
can't just think you're awesome and just
go out there you have to
you have to be like picking apart
everything you do but there's a balance
to that
too because you have to have enough
confidence to go out there and perform
you can't think oh my god i suck
i know what i'm doing but i know what
i'm doing because i put in all that work
and one of the reasons why i put in all
that work is i don't like
the i don't like the end result most of
the time so i need to work at it all the
time
and then there's physical struggle which
i think balances everything out
without physical struggle i i always
make the analogy that the body
is in a lot of ways like a battery where
if you have extra charge
it's like it leaks out of the top and it
becomes unmanageable and messy
and that's how my psyche is if i if i
have too much energy if i'm not
if i'm not exerting myself in a
violent way like an explosive way like
wearing myself
out i just don't like the way the world
is i don't like the way i interface with
the world i'm too tense
i'm i'm i'm too quick to be upset about
things up to
but when i work out hard and
you know i put in a brutal training
session everything's fine
you